pick a musical that's based on a movie
wait so we're choosing the musical not
the movie cuz my answer would be
different a musical wait musical
that's based my my choice is Billy
Elliot I'm Tom Holland and I play Billy
in Billy Elliott the musical and these
are all based off a movie yes yeah
waitress is based off a movie yeah yeah
I'm a big Barrett stand so Heather's the
music world I was in it in like
Community
Theater
Ensemble yeah but nobody heard me I did
it
quiet I'm choosing on that's like
another thing that I think is integral
to my lore really I'm sorry I don't even
know why I said like really I've never
seen the movie I've never seen the
musical so I don't even know where that
came from from me and I'm so sorry what
are you choos okay I forgive you I'm
choosing waitress what you I'm choing
waitress waitress strong